everyone makes mistakes
even in a galaxy far far away not even
Jedi Masters Sith Lords or George Lucas
are free from the occasional blunder
Star Wars assured in a new era of
digital special-effects and filmmaking
but the filmmakers behind it all are all
still human if you look beyond the
lightsabers it's apparent in the
mistakes and missteps you can find in
each of the movies in the saga and
that's not even counting Jar Jar Binks
nature's biggest mistake is embarrassing
uh Kira who there's a reason people
forget Keira Knightley was in the
Phantom Menace the British actress plays
sabe a quiet handmaiden who serves as
the costume decoy of Natalie Portman's
Queen Amidala through most of the movie
being a fake-out queen isn't much of a
role but the fact that Keira Knightley's
first name is misspelled in the end
credits probably doesn't help either her
handmaidens don't have very good luck
Padme clean this droid up as best you
can head of the class although the Jedi
young links that Yoda trains in attack
of the clones are capable of some
astounding things one appears to be just
a little more capable than the rest the
little guy with the reptilian face who
starts the shot out near the middle of
the group is suddenly behind everyone
after an angle change and then at the
head of the class after a quick cut it's
probably just a continuity error but it
could also be a pretty solid Jedi trick
we'll never find out
thanks Anakin the disappearing jacket
who knows what weird stuff you might
find inside a Jedi's home when Luke
Skywalker swings by obi-wan Kenobi's hot
to try out his dad's lightsaber in a new
hope there's initially a jacket hanging
from the archway the weapon of a Jedi
Knight but after a cut it's nowhere to
be seen
did you miss it must have gone to the
dark side or maybe just the laundry the
vanishing stormtrooper in a new hope
obi-wan Kenobi uses the Force to
convince stormtroopers that c-3po and
r2d2 aren't the droids they're looking
for these aren't the droids
looking for but apparently he could have
just made him disappear after a quick
cut the stormtrooper who is right behind
them suddenly vanishes Jedi trick or
impromptu lunch break
Vader's quick change during Darth Vader
and obi-wan Kenobi's epic lightsaber
battle at the end of a new hope
Vader gets pretty mixed up and not just
because obi-wan evaporates into his own
robe the buttons on Vader's chest plate
first appear on the right then they
switched to his left
if only switching between the light and
the dark sides were so easy model
misbehavior the battle sequences on Hoth
in the Empire Strikes Back were
larger-than-life especially because of
the Empire's
enormous Imperial walkers but looking
back some of the practical special
effects seem a little crude after Luke
blows up the guts of one of the massive
war machines with a grenade it comes
tumbling down now watch the back leg you
can't miss the pole used to tip over the
miniature model which comes out of the
ground and quickly retracts not so slick
millennium fly by George Lucas took
special effects light years into the
future but he's timid industrial light
magic were learning on the job
to depict asteroids they used everything
from old shoes to potatoes in a view
from the helm of the Millennium Falcon
during the Empire Strikes Back
you can briefly see the Millennium
Falcon fly past itself it's blurry but
that's hard ship doing a barrel roll
from an unused scene that's some
impressive flying crazy Carbonite being
frozen alive in a block of Carbonite
can't be a ton of fun but Han Solo seems
to have found a way to let loose his
arms are clearly bound behind his back
when he's lowered into the freezing
chamber in the Empire Strikes Back but
when he set free and Return of the Jedi
solos arms are somehow unshackled what
really happened there Lando flips Lando
Calrissian borrows a perplexing move
from Darth Vader during his appearance
in Return of the Jedi as he playfully
calls his pal han Solo
a pirate Calrissian is suddenly shown
wearing all his clothes the opposite way
Rey makes her point
in the force awakens it's pretty clear
that Rey is far from an ordinary young
woman but at one point she does
something pretty extraordinary on board
the Millennium Falcon as she and fin are
repairing the ship she points it
something with a right hand in a
close-up the wide shot shows her
pointing with the left thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know which star wars mistakes
you've caught